[Music]  there is only one  question that matters  do you swear on your life  [Music]  that what you say is true  [Music]  my father told me my life will be  blessed with good fortune  i'm married  [Music]  i was a good wife  and then was judged and shamed by my  country  [Applause]  i say before all of you  i spoke the truth  the most unspeakable charge has been  brought against you  chuckling entered our home  he attacked me the accusation is false  i am telling the truth the truth does  not matter  there is only the power of men  this should be settled quietly innocent  i request a duel to the death if you  lose  your wife will suffer dire consequences  one of us has lied let us let god decide  you do not believe me i am risking my  life for you  you are risking my life so you can save  your pride  penalty for bearing false witness  is that you are to be burned alive  i will not be silent  [Music]  you